hello everybody and welcome to another
Python tutorial series this series is
going to be dedicated to the use of
Python with sentiment analysis for the
use of you know finance so trading
investing so kind of a shift that we've
been seeing over the years has been
institutions becoming more and more
interested in the use of sentiment
analysis or even just macro data
analytics for the use of investing in
trading as is kind of a it's a not only
a new field but it's very hard field and
difficult field for anybody to get into
for a few reasons one it's just kind of
a deep and convoluted field but also
it's very expensive to get into so just
buying the data from a source like
Twitter or something like stock to its
which is like you know Twitter just for
stocks that's gonna cost you something
like five to fifteen thousand dollars a
month just to get data from these
companies and then you've still got a
performance sentiment analysis on that
and that's going to be another probably
five to ten thousand dollars a month if
not more so it's very costly to get into
this luckily I happen to know a guy
right so I have a website and that
website is sent Dexcom and we track
sentiment analysis for companies so I've
got a massive database so we have we
track over the entire Russell 3000 we
tracked the TSX 250 so of Canada stocks
the ASX 300 Aussie stocks and the FTSE
100 so GB stocks so we have all that
we've got a massive database but I don't
want to dump the entire database but I
will dump just the S&P 500 stocks and so
I was going to give that as just a
simple download on send XCOM so anybody
can just combine download this data set
so it's about I'll put it as a tarball
so tar.gz and so it's about maybe 80
megabytes to download it will extract to
about 400 megabytes and it's about 4.5
million rows of data on all these
companies so it's a good a decent sized
data set covers the about 1.5 years some
of them go up to about two years like
Apple was the first company then
he added Google and Microsoft and then
over time more and more came really
about 1.5 years is the size of the bulk
of the data and this is good and this is
bad I mean 1.5 years is a good time
frame but in the grand scheme of things
it's not especially when we consider
what has been going on in the stock
market for the last 1.5 years the most
part we've had a ton of QE and so the
stock market's really not even gone
through a cycle I mean it's just just
gone up so it's not the like I would
like to test a state of [ __ ] like 10
years of data and you know a huge cycle
so that'll be good
in a few more years maybe we'll reload
anyway so that's the data set that we're
gonna work with I'll go more into depth
on that data set it's also this SP 500
ish and I say that because it's actually
got about 600 companies in it and it
also includes Bitcoin as well as gold
oil silver and copper and we're actually
going to be filtering those out of the
data set especially Bitcoin because
that's completely unrelated but it is
there if anybody wants to play with it
and the data itself comes from does not
come from Twitter or stock to it so we
do do analysis on Twitter and stock
Swiss but we don't actually publicize
any of that data and so this is just
stock our information from companies
like you know like you know forbes New
York Times Barron's this kind of these
news hubs that release data we go
through their spider pull that data and
analyze for sentiment there so we get
that from about 20 major new sources and
then we've also got another probably
about 20 smaller new sources that just
don't put out as much data just kind of
what the data set looks like we'll pull
that apart a little bit more later on
and explain what everything means in the
data set that's just some of the basics
of what we've got so some of the
problems that we have with this kind of
analysis is that the data the two data
sets you know basically stock prices and
sentiment analysis are not married okay
so what this means is yeah sometimes
they're correlated in the sense that if
stock price just jumps a whole bunch
suddenly sentiment a lot of times will
jump based on the fact that a stock
price went up and we're all excited you
know that kind of stuff or if stock
price goes up it's highly
that some journalist somewhere is gonna
write an article on it and it's probably
gonna be a positive article you know
because the stock price went up so
there's obviously a reason so sometimes
a Cantrell price okay and sometimes it
beats price but what we need to do is we
have to understand that because it
trails price we don't want to find
ourselves in a situation where we have a
trading strategy based on sentiment yet
we find ourselves buying after price has
already gone up so buying at the high
and then doing the same thing and
selling at the low that's what we want
to avoid so we'd want to be able to so
after we have to marry the data back
together again and we have to reference
both bits so probably the first round of
this video and the series is going to be
we're gonna try and keep things as
simple as possible this whole topic it's
very in-depth very fast so we want to
keep things simple enough to start but
anybody who's brave enough to continue
on will dig a little deeper and will
start marrying the two bits together but
first we're just going to try and trade
completely blind of what the price is at
the time and just see do we even make
any money at all trading just blindly on
sentiment so we'll find out how that
works so that's the idea that's what
we're gonna do in this video we're going
to go ahead and download pandas download
other dependencies and download the data
set that will dump from centex and then
from there we'll just test the
installation real quick and then we'll
carry on in the next video and there
we're gonna be just doing a real quick
run-through of pandas some of the basics
of pandas how to work with it manipulate
data and then we're gonna go ahead and
hop into our data set and start you know
really working with pandas so and the
data so anyways let's go ahead and get
the data set get pandas and all that
alright so now we're ready to download
first I guess we'll get the data set so
to get the data set you're gonna head to
syntax doc home slash downloads slash
stocks underscore I think it stocks
index dot CSV dot GZ so it's not toward
OGG a lot just as gzip of the CSV hit
enter good and that will download your
stock saw syntax so this is the database
dump okay so while that's downloading we
can also head over we need to get pandas
and we also need
Matt plot live and we want numpy if
you're on Windows the easiest thing to
do is to head over to this website here
it's basically this I'll put the link in
the description if I forget to put links
in the description like I do a lot
please do just leave a comment I'll put
them in there but anyway as we head over
here and we can type in pandas click on
this and it takes us to the pandas here
and this actually tells us a lot of the
requirements so this is gonna require an
umpire date utility Z and very quickly
we're gonna require matplotlib because
we're gonna want to plot up stuff pi
tables all kinds of other stuff that
gets used very frequently so so what I
suggest that we do is we download all of
the things that we need now I'm assuming
everybody has Python installed if you
don't go to Python org and here we'll
head over to downloads and you can
either download Python 3 4 or 2 7 for
this series I'm assuming everyone is
using Python 2.7 it would have been
really nice to use Python 3 but
everything is not yet supported for
Python 3 so it can be very tedious if
you're trying to use Python 3 so I
suggest Python 2 7 now I have the 64 bit
version so I would download all 64 bit
version things if you're using a 32 bit
version of Python get all the 32 bit
downloads if you were on Windows this is
very easy you will download everything
so you'd click on pandas and that would
start your panda's download for you and
then you would want to go ahead and just
I hold ctrl on the keyboard and hit
numpy date until PI TZ and all of these
saipan methylate PI tables blah blah
blah and now I've just created a whole
bunch of windows here right and so now
you can download numpy you can download
date you till all these things get them
downloaded ok this one's still loading
but if you're not on Windows obviously
you still need to download all these
things I would at least start by
downloading pandas numpy date util
matplotlib and probably bottleneck but
maybe not bought on that
if you're not on Windows just keep that
in mind and otherwise if you're not on
Windows you need to go to numpy org get
numpy you could also get the SyFy stack
if you wanted also you'll need
matplotlib so go to matplotlib org to
download that and then pandas you can
come here and download pandas as well I
think that they give you the source of
yeah on the pi PI page so if you're not
on Windows that's how you need to get
these so once you have all these
downloaded install them and now what
you're gonna want to do is actually
check the installation so go ahead and
pause the video while you're downloading
everything and whenever you're done
downloading and installing everything
will continue on so once you've got
everything downloaded you're gonna want
to test your installation make sure you
can import and use his stuff so the most
important thing is we want to import
pandas so you want to make sure that you
can type import pandas in your IDE so I
just opened up Idol and we're just
typing this one this in we can import
pandas that's great
next thing you want to be able to import
numpy because we're gonna use numpy a
lot so you want to make sure that works
and then also you want to make sure we
can import matplotlib
as long as you can import these three
things we're ready to proceed in the
next video we will start using some
other dependencies as well let me go
back over I would at least make sure
that you have numpy date util and PI TZ
downloaded ok this other stuff and
except for matplotlib I suppose you make
sure you download math what looks we're
gonna use that really quickly this other
stuff you could hold off if you're not
on Windows because it's kind of tedious
to download and install all this stuff
so anyways that's that make sure you can
do all this import pandas numpy
matplotlib if you're getting any errors
or you can't figure out how to install
something feel free to leave a comment
in the comment section below and I'll be
guys out with your installation and all
that as long as everything is all set
though you're ready to continue onto the
next video and that next video is going
to cover just some of the quick basics
we're just gonna run through some of the
basics of pandas we're gonna grab some
data plot some data play with some of
the data and all that so stay tuned to
the next video as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the supported
subscriptions and it's um